pas oublier trop élevé pour qu'il y ait
deux pattes en peluche ne vous trompez
pas aussi bien sur vos droits
il lui manque un bon vous allez rendre
profitable secondes exactement la bulle
cool pour moi
non non tout est pour moi on fait une
tête
personne ne me crie souvent jour son
jardin de l'autre c'est parce que la
baisse que des trous petit voilà on se
posera un cousin pas ta belle tient le
manche témoin et reçoit de la france en
aof
vous avez entendu qu attaquer oui il
faut faire quelque chose
je n'aime pas quand pat asut et triste
bon qu'elles n'ont jamais très longtemps
pat asus veut recevoir du courrier
eh bien il faut lui écrire ma cuba lui
ai cru toi pathak longs mois tout le
monde nous nous y mettrons depuis ce
soir et comme enseigneront nous avec de
faux noms et et que la branche
donnerons-nous que celle de mes cousins
c'était mes cousins que je préviendrai
bas avant pas être facile
cher petit ami inconnu
je te vois souvent de loin et je me
demande qu'est ce que je peux bien lui
demander quelles sont tes goûts
[Musique]
moi virgules j'aime beaucoup tout ce qui
concerne la mécanique le sport coin
surtout le football points et toi point
d'interrogation
voyons voyons moi j'habite une petite
maison dans un jardin avec des fleurs et
des légumes
moi je préfère les
[Musique]
j'aime beaucoup la campagne
j'ai bien de la chance de ne pas vivre
en ville
[Musique]
et toi comment vis-tu j'espère que tu me
répondras très vite
t'as vu ta zut je viens de croiser le
facteur ya quatre lettres pour toi
tintin c'est pas vrai je ne mens jamais
ils n'ont pas d'âge ou pas par ses
mérites
monsieur pour qu'on regarde à porter le
courrier commune va être content mon
petit papa mécanique ça m'intéresse pas
eh ben dis donc j'espère que tu vas
répondre à tous tes nouveaux amis ah bah
voilà comment je ne connais pas sa joie
au plus elles sont bâties la trop haut
pour moi j'en passe très mal
combien croyez-vous qu'il y ait de patin
pêcheurs ne vous trompez pas
mon petit bien sûr vaudois par ailleurs
il lui manque un
pour nous en tout cas
[Musique]